[BEEPING]
SPEAKER: You've made it to
the last lab in the quest.
After you complete
this lab on Qwiklabs,
you will finally
unlock your badge.
So let's just get right to it.
In this episode, we'll be
talking about Google Compute
Engine.
Google Compute Engine
delivers virtual machines
running in Google's
innovative data centers
and worldwide fiber network.
Compute Engine's tooling
and workflow support
enables scaling from instances
to global load balanced cloud
computing.
Compute Engine's
VMs boot quickly,
come with persistent
disk storage,
and deliver consistent
performance.
Our virtual servers
are available
in many configurations,
including predefined sizes
or the option to create
custom machine types optimized
for your specific needs.
In this hands-on
lab, you'll learn
how to launch a Windows Server
instance on Google Compute
Engine and connect to it using
the remote desktop protocol.
If you aren't using Windows
on your local machine,
install a third party RDP
client such as Chrome RDP
by Fusion Labs.
One more thing that I personally
love about Google Compute
Engine is that
our infrastructure
is entirely carbon neutral.
Our global network
of data centers
consume 50% less energy than
the typical data center.
And we purchase enough
renewable energy
to match 100% of
the energy consumed
by our global operations.
We are growing our global
data center footprint
so your applications can
run closer to your customers
and distribute geographically
for resiliency.
I think that's pretty cool.
And is this it?
Is this the last
lab on your quest?
Congratulations.
We want to hear from you.
Tell us about your experience
following this Qwiklabs quest
and how you're
applying what you've
learned in your own applications
in the comments below.
Show off your badge and
tag us on social media.
See you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]